m
[Musique]
mais non
on
non
vous
oui
ces dernières années on a observé une
recrudescence des violences et des
outrages les sapeurs-pompiers sont
agressés de la même manière que les
policiers en fait on s'en prend à
l'uniforme à ceux qui semblent
représenter l'autorité
même si le métier de pompier n'a pas
vocation à gérer l'ordre public
on s'attaque aux symboles de l'uniforme
mais dans l'uniforme il y à des hommes
et des femmes
[Musique]
il
cette nuit un sapeur pompier a été
blessé par arme à feu alors qu'il
intervenait pour éteindre un incendie
soutien indéfectible à ce qui nous
protège au péril de leur vie
j'ai veillé à ce qu'une plainte soit
déposée ces actes odieux ne doivent pas
rester impunis